get ready to learn some very bad things
president Trump reacting to major
developments in the DOJ review of the
start of the Russia probe it's now a
criminal investigation the change
significant because it gives us attorney
John Durham the power to subpoena
witnesses impanel grand juries and filed
charges
we're also learning that Durham's
investigation has expanded because of
new evidence and he is very interested
in talking to former obama intelligence
officials John Brennan and James clapper
the president weighed in earlier it
looks like it's becoming very serious
from what I'm hearing investigate the
investigators whether it's stripped and
page whether its proper and whether it's
Comey and all of these people because
terrible things went on for our country
and we have a great Attorney General
highly prestigious man a very honorable
man and they've been looking at it for a
long time I can't tell you what's
happening I will tell you this I think
you're gonna see a lot of really bad
things Geraldo it is a significant
development the president's saying he's
gonna leave it to the Attorney General
but he's giving all of these hints that
he might have been told what's going on
well that is a probability I would guess
Dana but the the substance of the answer
is that there's some night sweat
epidemics going on in Washington right
now there are people who have been
pressing this false narrative for over
two years
this whole Russia hoax at some point
they had to know there was no there
there and yet they carried on and
issuing all of these subpoenas all these
perjury traps wearing you know hidden
microphones into meetings with the
President of the United States and his
staffers creating a climate of terror in
the White House all of it false the
collusion narrative a hoax for over two
years and 45 million dollars we were led
down this path you know Russia Russia
Russia it became a bad joke how the
president maintained his sanity
throughout this this ordeal is a great
mystery I think that the people that
engineered this the people who crafted
this hoax the people who drew the
country down the
in two hours will at some point have to
pay the piper I have no time just wait
did someone actually wear a wire inside
the Oval Office remember rod Rosenstein
but we're not saying that we're not
saying here that somebody wore a wire
inside the oval how'd they get generally
how did they catch I don't mean how did
they I mean I don't never heard that
somebody actually wore a wire inside the
Oval ah I stand literally corrected
although my general point is well made
that they leaked stuff entrap rod
Rosenstein was joking when he said that
you I think it's one of those things I
think that's how you try and get a
throuple together you go how about the
three of us getting married
ha just kidding but I'm not I think
that's what rod Rosenstein was doing but
now it's very interesting because I
don't think he was trying to engage and
any sort of a new marital concoction but
what I am saying is there were forces
working against the president and it's
now looking as though some of these
things that at one point in our very
recent past we would call conspiracy
theories are bearing out in a way that
it's happening so quickly with such
depth and breadth it's it's hard to wrap
your head around and you understand the
forceful NIF's with which the president
defends himself because he really feels
like he was unfairly painted into a
corner and someone really went after him
and I appreciate the tenacity with which
geraldo defends him although I felt like
I was sitting next to Jesse Watters rod
Rhodes and sign isn't apparently a part
of the new investigation they Greg they
want to talk to James clapper and
Brandon from the Obama in the trash you
know the what I do you mind if I pass
the media I'm gonna take a break okay I
love how the media is saying you know
this investigation into the Russian
probe is just another conspiracy theory
and they mock the Republicans for this
conspiracy theory it's like the Real
Housewives of New Jersey calling you
trashy alright they've been pushing
conspiracies for three years they push
them more than Michael and Dale pushes
pillows here's a deal this impeachment
is predicated on the point that they
know that they can't win and
election so they're like that stupid kid
who is terrified of failing a final so
what does he do he calls in a bomb
threat this is their bomb threat this is
their way of not facing the music not
facing an election but there's good news
here I think I think the tide is turning
against the Democrats because the
process is so out of proportion to the
infraction there's so much effort to
produce so little it reminds me of the
Oscars right it starts out interesting
like you start watching the Oscars the
first half an hour is great but when
it's over when the Oscars are over you
only remember one thing how it went on
too long
how bloated and grotesque it was how
pointless and how it wasted your time
that's how this process is going to look
to America the longer it goes on the law
the more likely the American public
would detest it then she'd treat it like
the Oscars get it over with and go to
commercial break yes problem though
because when you look at them they're
teen up for what they said that the DOJ
has losses independence they said that
this is political revenge and when I
really look at it they're against the
good old boys system right and I don't
mean to mask government workers but
within the Department of Justice there
is a good envoy system they protect
themselves but Jonathan Durham is not
one of those guys Durham is a guy that
is one that has investigated them before
but investigated the CIA before and so
this is a guy that was good enough for
holder he's a good enough for Trump as
well I got this past bipartisan support
but has staked his career after going
out of going after corruption he did on
the CIA he declined he said there was
previous investigation found no criminal
wrongdoing by the CIA officers all right
we have something else though because
the battle over impeachment is still
raging Republicans have been demanding
that the whistleblower
testified publicly but now Democrats are
reportedly claiming that hearing from
the whistleblower is no longer necessary
it comes as the left and the media
continue to mock and attack the GOP
after they stormed the closed-door
hearing this week this looks like a Klan
group that has assembled outside of a
jail trying to get the sheriff to let
them in so they could deliver their own
just
just against somebody was inside it's
not a good look for our democracy is not
a good look for the Republican Party and
AOC is joining in calling it a quote
little little flash mob or of
entitlement and privilege Greg they had
they did a stunt they did trying to make
a point actually won the new cycle for
the day did it look like the Klan how
can it be a Klan if there are no
Democrats it was all Republicans I mean
III seem to remember the Klan was made
up of Democrats look we know what kills
me about that's that point this was
racist no there's a racist comment man
was a racist that was a racist comment
yes it is I I kind of agree but I what I
find interesting Geraldo and I think
you'll find this interesting is let me
I'll say alright when I base when faced
with real mobs right chasing people out
of restaurants going to people's homes
hitting Trump supporters if you called
them a mob it was the media that called
you racist remember you weren't supposed
to use the M word that was only like two
months ago but now you can see some some
guys and guys and some women politicians
lawmakers go to a meeting and they call
that a mob of white people the Klan so
you're right I agree with you and you
agree with me let's go get a drink
Republicans should be more diverse
there's no doubt about it but you get
what the point is the point is that
there are a lot of them Republicans who
feel this process is grotesquely unfair
yeah and you know I you know they say
it's about process it is about process
it about due process the president gets
due process you can't do it in private
you didn't do it in private in 98 you
didn't do in private in 74 and they
can't do it in private now I say the
president should do nothing to cooperate
with these people unless and until they
open those here you should be his lawyer
I think I feel very strongly about this
and to Kennedy's point that I sound like
Jesse Watters I think that all Americans
should be offended by the fact that we
sang this Russia dance for
two-and-a-half years spent all this
money for nothing because they watch the
steel dossier that that golden shower
what did they base this on what's that
the Golden Corral that is the wonderful
Buffalo
not so much yes my grandmother well
they're gonna have public hearings but I
think this is a time for Americans and
lawmakers to reevaluate their past
decisions everybody loved the FISA Court
for so long Republicans and Democrats
rallied it around for the FISA Court
when many libertarian said don't trust
that court and it's not a it's not a
seaman you disagree on it but there's no
due process and so now we have instances
like this where Americans are spying on
a sham an investigation and all they
could say is look well at least we've
got a one from the Michael Horowitz the
IG of the inspector general at the
Department of Justice says I think it's
probably within the next couple of weeks
or so that we're going to have his
report that focuses only on the what the
FBI's role yes but now it's very
interesting because there are
Republicans who are conveniently talking
about things like the deep state and
talking about the surveillance apparatus
in a way that they're offended by yet
they were the ones who allowed the state
to get this bloated and and they realize
people in power all you have to do is
set a couple of traps in secret this is
completely opaque we have no idea how
this court works we really don't know
how the application process works or
what kind of oversight they have once an
application is okayed and you can
examine change some policies what
procedure the other thing too is doesn't
it libertarians have been begging
Republican I know there might I don't we
don't know what the results of this herb
maybe there was a problem with this
particular one I don't think that means
that the entire FISA Court process of
which has been very useful in terms of
protecting national security should be
thrown out with it and open it that just
has to be a different way and also well
that's what the investigation by the IG
will uncover did wiretap the Trump Tower
we can see from different than wiretap
the Trump Tower I bet all of the all of
the paranoia I'm just interested in like
how can how convenient is it not to need
the whistleblower anymore
blow this whistle and then they dig it
so what they need is impeach mission to
find the crime that the whistleblower
announced so now that they have the will
to crack the crime the whistleblower can
leave whistleblower was a FISA judge if
that's who it is I think it's John
Bolton and he's in cahoots with Adam
Schiff yeah I think it's a professional
Democrat I think it's a Media Matters
type person that's right we don't know